today's question comes from lisa
in kentucky she writes my husband and i
are debt
free the house that we live in was
purchased as a gift to us from his
parents
the house is completely paid for however
there's always a however dave
the house is not in our name i do not
feel secure without the house being in
our name
we have a great relationship and i trust
my in-laws but i have an issue with this
what should i do so my first
thought here dave is if somebody buys a
house for you and gives it to you but
it's not in your name
it's not your house is that a poor way
to look at that no
it's not it's like they bought a house
and letting you live in it no
there's not it's not a gift until it's
in your name there you go
so is it out of line here to have that
conversation
yeah i i and i think the way you always
have a conversation like that
is it's very very important to
put a lot of icing on the cake before
you start talking about this and the
icing the a lot of sweetness
yup and that's gratitude absolutely how
grateful you are and i
would never want to seem ungrateful and
we're not ungrateful and we are so
thankful
and so forth um it does make us
uncomfortable that it's not in our name
and we want to know when we're going to
get it into our name or
we're getting a will done and we need to
make sure all these assets flow in a
certain place yeah that's
fine but but bottom line is is that
this is weird yeah i would not give my
kids a house and leave it in my name
okay yeah it's just because then it's
not their house it's
their house yeah i mean let me give you
an example okay
her father-in-law is working second
shift and he falls asleep at the wheel
and he uh goes across the center line
hits somebody
and a kid is killed on the other car
they're taking that house too taking
that house that's right because it's his
asset
when they sue him for 500 million
dollars the judgment lien will be on
the house that is not hers right
hmm and that's called an accident
right that i described absolutely the
father-in-law did anything wrong no no i
didn't call him a drunk he wasn't drunk
driving i didn't call him anything i
didn't say anything negative about him
right
but it's just you know he could you know
he could
have a business go bad and get an rs
lien and
guess what the irs lien is on all of his
assets right and this house is his asset
not hers right so and the other piece of
advice i would just give you is
um uh uh you don't talk
let your husband talk it's his parents
you can sit there
with a smile on your face and the only
thing you're allowed to say is how
grateful you are
right i want you to know how grateful
you are right you're not allowed to
make the mic body language or grimaces
or words that are part of this
conversation that has at its essence
conflict in it
because you're going to get labeled as
the cause of it ah
you're going to be labeled as the
dissension but in the family yeah right
yeah the
evil it would have been okay if it's my
son but his wife got
there you go so they say something along
the lines of well
we will we're not comfortable doing that
now
but we will in my head i immediately
switched to this isn't our house
we we are living rent-free in my parents
house we now are saving up for our own
place yep
and then i'm off to the races there
exactly i'm going to use i'm not going
to
sleep over it thank you for the free
rent and i'm gonna use that to save up
and buy my own house
i'm not gonna throw a fit about it i'm
not gonna whine about it we're gonna go
buy ourselves a house
yeah well you said it was a gift we're
moving on we're moving on we're just
gonna
look if you're not gonna put it in my
name it's not a gift you gotta have that
clear
logic in your head so the other thing
about this lisa is
is that you want you need to hear loud
and clear from john we're saying you're
right
absolutely yes you're right you're not
crazy this has got some weirdness on it
there's something weird here and i don't
know what it is it may be a simple thing
that
they've they haven't had good tax
planning that nobody showed them how to
do it
without getting it without getting a
gift tax bill
because you know if they'll see a good
tax planner they can teach them how to
do
to transfer an asset that size as a gift
without having any gift tax
under the unified estate gift tax credit
and it's one piece of paper with their
filing of their taxes this year and
unless they have an estate over 20
million dollars it won't affect their
state taxes a dime
so um there's lots of ways to do this
they may just not know how to do it
and there's you know but but if that's
the only reason but
i'm gonna guess and say that's not the
reason i know something about this field
ziki dave
yep but yep
interesting that the son didn't ask the
question
he's the guy i want to talk to in this
yeah he's the one he's because he's the
one going
through the talking right if this is
handled properly
he needs to deal with his mama not his
wife dealing with his mama yes
because i can just tell you this is how
this is going to go down